il partait outsiders pourtant ils l'ont
fait le TVB nous a offert un match de
haut niveau et un golden 7 dans une
ambiance survoltée samedi soir à Tours
les joueurs tournent en jour ont brillé
face à Chaumont et ont décroché pour la
9e fois le titre de champion de France
une victoire célébrée avec des
supporters en liesse dans les tribunes
de la salle Grenon retour sur cette
soirée de folie avec Aurélie Renaud
c'est dans une salle complète et
chauffée à blanc que le tour volley-ball
remporte son 9e titre de champion de
France face à Chaumont c'est
exceptionnel ce qu'on vit ce soir on
part de très loin après le match qu'on a
fait à Chaumont maintenant a été
confiant avec notre public on était
capable de faire ce genre de performance
je pense qu'on a prouvé ce soir qu'on
était la meilleure équipe de la saison
on est organisé c'est un vrai bonheur un
vrai bonheur il y a pas de bon il y a
une vraie osmose et je pense que s'ils
avaient pas été là peut-être que les
trois premiers 7 on les aurait pas gagné
à cette vitesse et que ça aurait été
très compliqué pour gagner ce tie break
qui nous fait devenir champion quoi dès
le début du match les tours en jeu
dominent ils sont solides ils ont la
rage et l'emporte 25 à 16 même score
pour le deuxième set durant le troisième
les chaumontés se battent mais le tour
volley-ball l'emporte à nouveau 27 à 25
puis les touranjos remportent le 7 en or
15 10 ils sont champions
merci beaucoup à tous les supporters
de France
c'est un gros bravo aux joueurs au
groupe parce que
on finit la saison des dernières jours
de la saison avec un titre c'est tout ce
que l'entraîneur avec ce titre les
hommes de Marcello francoviak s'offre
ainsi un doublé après avoir remporté la
Coupe de France début avril face à Nice